il
[Musique]
alors on salue la planète sur quelle
caméra les numéros transmis ça s'appelle
celle là et là c'est celle ci celle-ci
celle là je vois chose qu'on n'a pas
droit parce qu'on serait pas comment
l'appeler l'autre et voici l'autre co
animatrice de l'émission a dit chantal
shenzhen bonjour aux ou stéphane on a un
troisième co animateur aujourd'hui il
s'agit de samir ben bon jour suivant sur
sa faim bonjour tout le monde bonjour
c'est bien il m'a écrit un exemple je
l'invité cette semaine par courriel je
sais très froid mon affaire je peux sont
souvent pas le temps il dit ça se refuse
pas une invitation de tintin comme c'est
gentil de ta part marie-claude semestre
numéro un pour jour et il est où gimeno
bonjour rien vous également venez blacks
et on a un grand menu important
aujourd'hui très sérieuses et l'avenir
de la planète et que ce qui va se
discuter
donc je vous aiguille déjà vers le sujet
de la de la semaine mais vous connaissez
la tradition je vous offre une vidéo 5
images vous devez deviner quel est le
thème précisément cette semaine qui
porte sur l'avenir de la planète
alors on rôle des ballounes non pas des
ballounes réchauffement climatique sur
wii oui mais encore comme dire en
français mais encore il ya eu lé dégel
le dégel ça c'est mieux c'est enfin
calotte c'est très très bien vous êtes
sûr de très bonnes pistes faux plafond
c'est un autre mot magique aujourd'hui
[Rires]
bravo
alors puis on en vint point ses effets
sur le canada mais aussi sur nos cousins
français
nos cousins britanniques on a aussi des
cousins à brittany enfin pas britannique
soyons précis après tout cette émission
est diffusée tout à fait est pas
difficile à travers le monde mais autour
du monde c'est compliqué je vous dis
cette affaire là alors aujourd'hui à tam
tam canada vous avez le thème vous
connaissez aussi la faire des jeux du
jeu il ya trois questions qu'on vous
pose des missions à chaque tour de
bouboule vous perdez des points ou pas
pour le premier tour ça commence de
façon très de façon très bening 20
points à perdre d'accord je vais voir ce
que je peux maintenant j'ai perdu les
trois derniers matches j'ai perdu tous
les points sans permis s'était sacrifié
ce prêt la calotte glaciaire du
groenland constitue la deuxième masse de
glace au monde ça je vous donne
d'informations comme vous le saviez pas
cette calotte glaciaire couvre environ
quel pourcentage de toutes ces
thématiques
est ce que c'est un 70 pour cent de
lille b 80% de lille où ces 90% de lille
mais attendez d aucune de ces réponses
70% 80% à 90%
aucune de ces réponses la glace
recouvrent quelle partie pourcentage de
cette île du groenland faire le tour
parce qu' en tout 90 portant parfait
excellent je dirais aucune de ces
réponses des ans qu'aucune de ses
hanches cela je réponds même si aucune
sa réponse qu'est ce que ce serait comme
réponse parce que c'est une île quand
même c'est pas cécilia et il y à du rock
en dessous donc fier des côtes
donc il ya des gens pour cent pour mon
30% seulement je dirais sans forcer sans
comme ça que j'imagine le guen a alors
90% 100% en cours sans aucune de ces
réponses
j'irai avec la réponse la plus belle
possible 70% 70%
c'est plus bête c'est lui c'est 30%
alors enfoncé aucune des trois réponses
alors écoutez lever la main celui ou
celle qui a 10 mai 81 % à 70 % bien
personne
donc vous avez tous perdu 20 points
c'est avec 80 % soit 1 80% à 70% en
étant proche
moi je dis 90 moi je voulais dire 75 en
fait écouter la prochaine fois je vous
donnerai pas de réponse c'est 80% ses
quartiers dans l'important c'est pas si
important jeu ce qui m'a beaucoup
intéressé cette semaine j'ai découvert
que c'était dit pas non seulement elle
n'est pas complètement recouvert de
glace il peut prendre ton aussi je vais
y est le printemps ils appellent ça la
débâcle
ils ont tout inventé à débattre et puis
ça se passe je pense du mois de mars au
mois de novembre mais écoutez je sais
comment nos membres ligue là les glaces
se reforme ce mot technique pour ça moi
je suis pas bon niveau technique on
attend de spécialistes l'émission à
quelques instants mais j'ai découvert ça
et je pense que je vais vous montrer une
vidéo et donc on connaît un peu plus
cette île le groenland on veut regarder
la fonte des glaces au blond aux grenat
le sujet principal de cette émission
des images que j'ai été chercher dans
différents reportages très sérieux
reuters bbc j'ai fait tout un
voici une comparaison 1992 2002 c'est
seulement là où on le range va se passer
fonds du ce est en train de fondre
est ce un bon c'est ça c'est plus
récemment encore là on montrait c'était
juillet je pense il y a 5 1 ou en
quelques jours toute la glace
pratiquement s'est mise à vendre 92% et
plus ne me citez pas encore une fois les
choses sont écrites je commence à lire
toute démission
je préfère parler on va laisser parler
le voici notre invité de marque
aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment quelqu'un
de
c'est grâce à ce que vous voyez j'ai un
prof en première classe professeur
fortier alors professeur et louis
fortier professeur titulaire faculté des
sciences de génie département biologie
université laval à québec et c'est une
des sommités mondiales dans le domaine
c'est une passion personnelle vous
occupez vous intéresser au monde de la
classe aux répercussions sur les
sociétés sur les habitants de ces
régions depuis combien de temps et j'ai
commencé mes premières armes en
subarctique à la vue du sang a fait en
hiver au printemps dans les années
soixante dix le milieu des années
soixante dix ensuite j'ai pris le
leadership canadien de quelques
expéditions internationales justement
grenade et ensuite ça dans les eaux du
nord qui sont alex rossi voulait de la
mère de ma faim et non pas comme prévu
du droit au sujet des merdeux de données
de bafang je pense que c'est pas l'aube
tellement loin de la mer de baffin moi
je m'y connais pas c'est le cas oui et
entre la terre de baffin excellent et on
se situe aujourd'hui il y avait un petit
reportage j'ai vu ça cette semaine je
pense était ainsi bissy il disait que
des plantes qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis
40 ans qui était enfouie sous la neige
la glace
quarante mille ans vient d'être aperçu
donc sa forme sa faune rapidement toute
cette région ça faudrait non l'ensemble
des glaciers de l'hémisphère nord font
très rapidement et aux firmes de que les
glaciers les graisses comme ça on voit
apparaître les le sol est aussi dans
certains cas la végétation qui était
présente au moment où ces glaciers se
sont formés donc
la dernière glaciation s'est faite il ya
environ cinquante mille ans a commencé à
progresser et aux furieux que les
glaciers avancent elles ont ils ont
recouvert en fait des végétations et là
il maintenant que les caisses on
retrouve cette végétation est
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'on peut
voir des plantes en très bonne état en
fait elles ne sont pas fossilisées
certains corps souvent organiques et on
peut déterminer toutes sortes de
paraître deux variables sur cette manche
oui c'est intéressant comme vous le
dites c'est aussi préoccupant pour ceux
qui se paye que peu de l'environnement
vraiment comprendre quelle est la
situation groenland j'ai lu beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de choses des fois qui
se contredisent
beaucoup de scientifiques entre eux qui
se contredisent sur la portée du
réchauffement il y en a qui disent
m'écouter ce on a déjà vu sans impasse
et ceo popelin des millions d'années la
sauce est déjà produit la fonte des
glaces pratiquement complète au
groenland donc peut-être que vous aller
un peu loin en parlant de réchauffement
climatique et a véritablement un débat
en ce moment le débat et pas au sein des
scientifiques en tant que telle la nasse
majorité des victimes at à l'heure où
des glaciologues son s'entendent sur le
fait que c'est surtout une série de
l'association des glaciations depuis
environ deux millions d'années lorsque
le l'isthme entre les deux américains
laisse ne veut pas n'a pas de panama
c'est fermé le système climatique de
munitions à mort s'est transformée et on
a vu apparaître en fait se développer
une série de glaciation et de
déglaciation dans une quarantaine depuis
ce temps-là est alors à l'heure actuelle
on est dans une
en fait au début de l'ère industrielle
on était dans une des glaciations donc
de réchauffement de l'ensemble de la
planète et ce qui devrait se produire
c'est que on est à peine de pousser ce
réchauffement alors à des niveaux encore
plus élevés
à l'heure actuelle avait depuis 5000 ans
le climat se rafraîchit très
tranquillement et depuis les lumières
industriels ont les navettes de pousser
la chaudière ça doit faire remonter les
températures salissent pour sa sortie
est ce qu'on devrait s'inquiéter de
cette situation là au regard du débat
qui divise le monde scientifique
aujourd'hui l'ailé quand je vous disais
le débat ne était intense au début du
21e siècle à partir des années 2000
jusqu'à 2010 à peu près et après ça on a
vraiment atteint le consensus du point
de vue scientifique qui a permis avec le
giec de commencer à influencer la
société a influencé les preneurs de
décision il ya encore aujourd'hui des
résistances les gens ont droit de croire
ce qu'ils veulent mais il tient suite ne
croit à rien les scientifiques ne se
base que sur les données c'est pas de
questions croyances pour nous on ne
croit pas au changement climatique où on
ne croit ou on croit au changement
climatique
nous tous nous c'est un fait c'est l'as
est en progression et ça ce ça se
développe est évident dans le monde
politique d'un autre côté il ya toujours
des rencontres des variations c'est on a
eu au canada ici un gouvernement qui
était pas particulièrement inquiété par
le changement climatique
maintenant on en a un qui pour qui c'est
une île une priorité en australie ça a
été exactement la même chose et aux
états unis on devine au maine faisant de
vue de l'administration obama qui fait
très fort pour réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre est maintenant d
une administration qui qui fait le
contraire alors prof ça fait juste ma
dernière question qu'est ce qu'on
devrait faire urgemment pour sauver la
situation
ben premièrement décrivant juste le
il ya plusieurs aspects mais juste celui
du groenland le groenland la calotte
glaciaire l'inlandsis immense qui est au
dessus de vous parler d'une île tout
cela c'est plutôt un archipel leur
mandat cet ipod touch fait et cette
calotte glaciaire là jusqu'à quatre
kilomètres d'épaisseur à certains
endroits et la vaste majorité de cette
classe là ne s'est pas de la banquise ça
c'est de la glace est au dessus du
niveau de la mer si elles font des
totalement demain ou s'écouler dans
l'océan atlantique l'océan arctique le
niveau des océans sur l'ensemble de la
planète se ré où serait de 7 m ce qui
fait qu on a environ 30 à 35 % de la
population mondiale qui soit se fait
pousser des parents chez soi des ménages
donc vous pouvez voir l'impact que cela
peut avoir
donc quand vous demandez qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire c'est quoi la solution à
l'heure actuelle si on n'arrive pas à
suivre les recommandations de l'accord
de paris et pour limiter nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
on dirige le réchauffement planétaire de
l'ordre de 3 4 degrés et d'ici peut-être
milan ou 800 ans l'ensemble de la
calotte du groenland va fondre et
s'écouler dans l'océan atlantique
besson n'a même pas commencé à parler
encore de l'immense inlandsis de leur
parti qu est ce donc professeur forte
que je ne dois pas de dormir
entre professeurs fortier vous parliez
tout à l'heure de glaciation des
glaciations moi je m'inquiéterais pas je
dirais que ça va prendre 5 millions et
puis ça va reprendre ce que on n'est pas
dans cette es ce que cette logique peut
fonctionner excellente
excellente question non ça ne fonctionne
pas sinon ouais d'un point de vue
biochimiques de viewsonic le co2 le gaz
carbonique qu'on aimait dans
l'atmosphère une fois qu'on va avoir
atteint des niveaux qui sont prévus pour
au moment où on va commencer vraiment
réduire nos émissions
ça va prendre de l'ordre de 15 à 20
mille ans avant qu on puisse résorber
c'est ces concentrations de co2 la et
amener un équilibre climatique qui
ressemble à celui qu'on a à l'heure
actuelle
non car on parle de réchauffement
climatique on parle pas pour les la
génération qui vient ou l'autre après on
parle pour toutes les générations après
arrêt total pour la civilisation comme
on la connaît à peu près vous remettez
vous voulez existe déjà mais l on parle
de 15 à 20 minutes supplémentaires donc
vous pouvez voir la porte
fortier glissant maintenant vers un
sujet toujours aussi délicat c'est la
question du changement des tendances
météo hiver au canada hiver en france on
au royaume uni un bien quand on a parlé
un peu plus tôt la question du golf
stream qui s'essouffle selon certains
rapports parce qu'il ya toute cette eau
qui commencent à tomber
pour utiliser cette image dans l'océan
atlantique
là où passe le goff swing et apparemment
ça complique les choses ça ralentit le
golf stream qui aurait alors une
incidence sur le climat des deux côtés
de l'atlantique et j'aimerais présenter
pendant que vous nous expliquer ce qui
se passe vraiment une vidéo tirée des
archives de cbc radio canada où on vous
montrent donc cette image du golfe wind
à quoi ça ressemble en ce moment à quoi
ça pourrait ressembler également dans
quelques temps alors qu'est ce qui se
passe exactement ces deux attendez moi
ça s'appelle le golfe et donald trump
c'est amusant de travail sens
donald trains à quai c'est pas la même
c'est pas de [ __ ] c'est la faute du
pilote
ok d'accord voilà qu'est ce qui se passe
avec le golf stream et qu'est ce qui va
se passer
le gulfstream et c'est un des grands
courants son appel en termes très
technique anodin graphie dans un courant
d'amplification à la marge occidentale
débat c'est aussi bon soit sur vous
diriez mais le bruit c'est le pendant à
l'antique ducourtioux européen le grand
courant qui passe le long du lac du
japon est assez grand couvent là même la
chaleur de l'équateur vers le nord c'est
à dire vers l'atlantique nord et le
pacifique que non et ce sont deux
segments si vous voulez deux boucles de
ce qu'on appelle un phénomène beaucoup
plus grand qu'on appelle la circulation
thermohaline profonde des moyens de le
dire température est celle qui se
produit c'est que pour line is fair mort
dans la mer du groenland dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure et la mer du labrador qui
était même tout près de chez nous dans
ces mers là en hiver il fait extrêmement
froid
la banque qui se forme cela la couche de
surface de l'océan qui gèlent au moment
où la couche de surface de l'océan gèle
que la barre qui se forment la banquise
rejette son recèle donc immédiatement
sous la banquise on va retrouver des
autres très salée est très très froide
en étang salé fouad ces lots sont denses
et elles vont s'enfoncer en profondeur
et si ce qui est le moteur de la
circulation pour moi l'une conformes
dont le rappel si vous voulez le dans la
croix c'est le goal swing ou le cloud
rock you dans l'hémisphère nord
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire mieux que le
groenland fond et que la banquise de
l'océan arctique fond ça amène
énormément d'eau douce dans la mer du
droit de man et dans la mer du labrador
skrek à damas qui se forment les eaux
qui se danse qui sont en tout sont un
peu moins dense parce qu'elles sont
moins solides et à sang le sang ralenti
l'ensemble de ceux qui la sous-tend
molines profonde et ce qui veut dire que
les des températures relativement douces
convoi en europe par rapport au québec
par exemple ou qu'on voit sur la côte
ouest américaine par rapport à la
sibérie ou à ce moment ces températures
d'oslo si ces grands courants le se
ralentisse s'arrête
ces températures vont se sont devenus
plus rude on va perdre 7 cet aspect père
et semble du climat européen et la côte
ouest qu arnaud vite nous hiver à nous
sera plus rude
ce qu'il ya pour d'autres nations aussi
des répercussions nous montrer que c'est
un convoyeur de chaleur mondiale
alors j'imagine que ce qui va se passer
ici dans notre région nordique pourrait
avoir des incidences par exemple
jusqu'en australie quelque part oui ça
c'est le climat de l'australie les
fluctuations dans l'hémisphère sud sont
plus liés au phénomène d'el niño un qui
sait les grandes sécheresses et tout ça
c'est en australie c'est l'élan chalon
vient de voir c'est une combinaison de
mignot et de réchauffement planétaire ce
qui les reds vont surtout avoir un
impact sur l'euro et sur la côte est de
l'amérique du nord
mais à l'heure actuelle il faut pas trop
s'emballer avec ça parce que la plupart
des modèles monde en lega les modèles
pour ce que ça vaut mais la plupart des
monnaies lmnp que le réchauffement
climatique va compenser en fait
réfléchissement qui pourrait être lié
par le ralentissement de la circulation
du courant du sud ah bon c'est l'os et
l'autre principe d'archimède
on l'a jamais utilisé à l'école mais
existe puisqu'il est question ici autour
de la table en fait on sait que le
gouvernement mais dépendante des
gouvernements ils forment qu ils font
contre l'histoire des eaux et quoi il
croit pas au changement climatique
qu'est ce qu'on fait au niveau de la
société pour aider pour que ça change
passe si vite que ça
ouais je sens une question très
intéressante
une analyse plus politique mais pendant
l'exemple des états unis le cheikh
voisins du sud ils sont maintenant les
deuxièmes plus grands émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre avant l'actuelle
l'administration centrale du tout
intéressé à réduire ses émissions là le
seul trump a décidé de retirer des états
unis du de la corde de paris mais ça
n'empêche pas que les les municipalités
et les états continue quand même à
accélérer la lutte contre les
changements climatiques sont la
californie par exemple il joue au
maximum leur mission parce que tu senti
la soupe chaude la voie des alternances
de sécheresse intense avec incendies
majeurs et parfois c'est suivies
d'inondations but sans vraiment là les
effets et maintenant vraiment d'effort à
réduire les émissions et c'est la même
chose pour beaucoup d'états aux états
unis donc malgré les changements
d'administration de santal que ce soit
le gouvernement canadien que ce soit le
gouvernement australien
les les entités politiques qui ont plus
de durabilité sont venus de pérennité
s'en dégage un peu dans le passé encore
mais il ya quand même une lueur d'espoir
ça veut dire que nos efforts ils font
bien la planète
nos efforts sont tout à fait insuffisant
maintenant mais au moins on attendrait
de décrocher le du scénario où ça va
être l'étape maximum dire que à
appréhender 1.5 à 2 degrés mais ça ce
sont les règlements 17s c'était voulu
on sait que l'on se dirige vers 3 ou 4
degrés de réchauffement en 2100 mais au
moins on n'est pas cinq ou six ou sept
et à l'heure actuelle juste pour vous
donner un chiffre un exemple en 2014
c'était 6% des énergies de l'énergie
seulement qu'ils étaient renouvelables
c'est de ce qu'on consomme en énergie
qui était de sources renouvelables en
2018 dans les rendus à 12% hockey et le
guen est exponentielle malheureusement
l'ensemble de l'utilisation d'énergie
augmente aussi parce que notre société
nos civilisations continue à se
développer et la population continue à
augmenter donc les nuls mais au moins la
proportion de cette de cette énergie
renouvelable augmenté vivement de façon
exponentielle
alice howie professeurs on sait que
l'action citoyenne concours à la lutte
contre les changements climatiques mais
il se pose un problème de moyens
qu'est ce qu'on devrait faire pour doter
la société civile de moyens suffisants
pour mener à bien son action selon vous
il ya énormément de pistes de solution
par exemple ici au québec
99 % de notre électricité est verte
donc c'est l'endroit idéal pour
développer la voiture électrique est
pour pour acheter les voitures étaient
si vous achetez une voiture électrique
dans certaines régions des états unis
ça donne strictement rien parce que
l'électricité que vous mettez des
produite à partir de charbon
donc si pire afin d'avoir une voiture
électrique que d'avoir une voiture à
essence tandis qu'ici c'est c'est pour
la société civile c'est une des actions
les plus positives qu'on veut mais si on
pouvait électrifié nos transports au
québec on rejoindrait la norvège la
suède et le danemark dans les pays en
fait de réduction d'émissions donc je
sais
ça c'est un exemple il ya énormément
d'autres choses qu'on peut faire on peut
faire que le produit soit même son
électricité avec photovoltaïque et c'est
la seule chose qu'on peut faire il faut
voter aussi pour le parti qui nous amène
vers des solutions en ce qui concerne à
l'essai plein d'électricité ce matin
l'or l'autre question rien aussi après
écoute et peut-être que vous prononcez
pas sur les mesures politiques mais
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous le marché
du carbone c'est à dire en fait si je
comprends bien c'est les entreprises qui
peuvent payer pour pouvoir aller d'abord
le droit de polluer finalement si on
veut résumer ça ainsi la whey en fait
c'est un peu juste un peu plus que ça
car même si on arrive à vraiment mettre
une valeur réelle sur les émissions de
carbone d'une valeur monétaire
on va bien meilleur contrôle des
émissions s'est dit que si on s'assure
que tout le monde paie pour ses
émissions ou que tout le monde qui ne
fait pas de mission ou puis autre
réduction des émissions négatives
reçoivent une compensation pour pour ça
ça devrait accélérer notre progression
vers une décarbonisation de la société
de l'énergie et l'industrie c'est de
l'économie finalement c'est un dix aidé
des outils les plus puissants
c'est extrêmement difficile à mettre en
place parce qu'il ya énormément de
résistance parce que ça touche à la
ligne de base c'est à dire est ce qu'on
appelle le
la ligne du bila sa touche aux fonds de
pension ctk fonds de pension qui
l'estiment beaucoup dans les énergies
fossiles à se lasser les énergies
fossiles bpa et aux élections font moins
d'argent pour moins de profits parce
qu'ils ne peuvent payer pour leurs
émissions
à ce moment là les fonds de pension sont
touchés les gens sont morts et c'est
tout ça c'est d'une complexité énorme
saut dans le monde financier
mais je pense que si on n'arrive pas à
faire jouer les lois du marché comme ça
allait faire travailler vers une
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre on y arrive au programme 30
secondes dernière question non dans le
format ma question est davantage
politique ne sais pas si c'est à vous
que je devrais la poser mais je la pose
tout de même comment agir contre cette
double discours de la part de différents
gouvernements à travers le monde qui
sont très écolo dans l'eure dans leur
façon de parler au monde mais qui dans
la réalité sont plutôt très très propres
aux propres au pétrole voilà il faut
qu'il faut bien comprendre évidemment
que le pétrole s'est vraiment lépine
dorsale de notre civilisation est que si
dans un pays donné
on arrête les succède au pétrole ou au
waou taxe trop le pétrole à ce moment là
ont ralenti l'économie qui devient plus
pop et ici par rapport aux autres
économies
ce qui est important c'est que tout le
monde le fasse en même temps et c'est ça
qui est ici pour faire sortir il faut
faire en battant c'est à peu près la
seule façon alors comment comment
combattre les populistes conservateurs
c'est en votant pense que la leçon
apprise c'est très bien professeur merci
beaucoup
nous avons fait arrêter votre retrouve
exigent votre savoir aujourd'hui très
apprécié merci ça m'a fait plaisir
avant c'était louis fortier professeur
titulaire faculté des sciences de génie
département de biologie à l'université
laval à québec
ainsi pas n'importe qui qui est un
attentat il a les digits y est je suis
extrêmement intéressés à venir vous
parler
je suis inquiet par entendu parler de
nous de réputation même journée
intéressante réputation il s'est dit 30
minutes avec pourparlers 30 minutes
ils font même pas à la télévision c'est
vrai on est prêt pour le jeu en ne
maintenant qu'on a beaucoup étudié
deuxième grosse boule de l'émission
temps point interne vous avez perdu vos
vingt premiers points tous voici pour
votre tous les mots maman avant ça t'es
pas seuls aujourd'hui
ok alors l'archipel pas les archipels du
groenland est recouvert à 80% par un
instant 10
comme l'a dit notre invité de façon si
quelques instants difficiles à tenir une
c'est une épaisseur qui atteignait
environ 4 c'est ça aussi la question
grâce à des images satellites et de
résonances je prends magnétique mais de
enfin de radar de la nasa
ils sont passés au dessus de l'archipel
ils ont découvert quelque chose
récemment sucette calotte glaciaire
qu'est ce que c'était a un trou géant
qui mène plusieurs km sous terre
est-ce que c'était bon un énorme cratère
d'apparence lunaire ou mvno mon affaire
sutter lunaire ou encore parce que
c'était c'est un canyon de la trempe du
grand canyon américaine gérer pour le b
mois le bébé un énorme cratère
d'apparence lunaire très bien c'est un
canyon vous aussi depuis toujours sur
l'autre à tanger pas copier mais non non
c'est vrai mais ces quatre kilomètres
tard c'est comme aux jeux parce que je
ne voyais pas traiter et personne à dix
a encore un trou géant qui m'a répondu
oui
et pour ça je vais je compile des deux
autres ouais canyon de la tempe du grand
canyon qui a répondu b non créateur
d'apple en super personnes a perdu deux
points
ces deux jours ont été découvertes comme
ça
j'ai deux bonnes réparé loi alors
d'avoir ça veut peut être plus généreux
après la promo alors le gran canyon a
été découvert en 2013 et ce à travers
sur la partie nord ouest le délai sa
mesure 750 km de long puissant 1 mètre
de profondeur c'est pratiquement trois
quarts de la qu'il avait parfois et puis
et puis l'autre affaire le cratère le
reste on va regarder ça c'est un [ __ ] est
sale découverte nasa anti trempe dans ce
projet est alors découverte nasa et ça
vous montre le cratère qui a été
découverte d'une caisse visant non ils
ont annoncé ça seulement cet été ou
l'été dernier j'avais vu 16 c'est un
c'est quelque chose qui est tombé un des
25 endroits dans le monde où on sait
qu'un météo est quelque chose qui est
tombé là c'est si vous enlevez la glace
de façon artificielle
vous retrouvez ces ils vont vous allez
voir l'empreinte de la ville de paris il
emprunte de la ville de washington pour
vous montrer à quel point c'est énorme
31 km de large et puis voilà paris tout
p'tits au centre alors mais c'est pas
encore fondu au flore atteindre dit-on
800 à 1000 selon notre invité voilà
s'amuse à cette chose amusante autre
chose les modèles défilent du film
d day after tomorrow va pas passer c'est
quoi ça le film l'edf du tout moi c'est
une film catastrophique en fait qu' ils
ont des modèles de destruction par les
changements climatiques
mais le gaouyat ce fait ces modèles là
d'ici à huit cents ans
mais les modèles s'accélère puisque face
à moi ok alors c'est la glaciation que
l'on voit c'est beaucoup de choses qui
se passent ces trois du groupe bien sûr
mais l'histoire c'était un modèle qui
existe mais qui le hisse et passe dans
très peu de temps on n'a pas le temps de
vendre sa maison puis de déménager par
contre on a le temps de mourir et de
ressusciter pour venir voir ça on va lui
sur notre page technique tu aimes tu
étais trump tomtom 30 rock et d'autres
dans cet épisode descends descends
descends descends voilà qu'est ce que
c'est que ça il ya quelqu un d pad
besoin d'une est ici
sentant plus tard une épave dans les
eaux arctiques canada regagne la norvège
est là je joue là vous cliquez dessus ça
c'est on a toujours des petites
vignettes des reportages qui
accompagnent notre sujet principal ça
c'est un des 17 sélections cette semaine
alice j'ai une de vos sélections
également je me souviens plus de
laquelle on se souvient plus alors ça
c'est l'été dernier navire comme ça
qu'ils avaient échoué et qui habite mme
en fait c'est un grand explorateur qui
avait explorer l'arctique où enfin là où
ceux de l'art l'antarctique voilà et
puis ensuite il a décidé d'aller faire
la même chose au dans l'arctique
canadien et là il s'est frappé au dur
climat canadien il a dû aborder son
bateau qui a fini par être vendus qui a
fini par couler il ya cent ans et on l'a
renfloué les norvégiens ont finalement
pu me mettre le grappin dessus
le ramener l'été dernier dans leur
nation comme sa ville et des coussins
gonflables
voilà je vous épargne les détails à lire
comme ça en images sur
radio canada c'est un trois mois un
trois-mâts devant moi mes factures moi
je écouter ça se passait dans les
territoires du nord-ouest
j'ai eu le temps encore pour un petit
jeu qui a perdu des points au dernier
bien troisième tour combien de points à
perdre 5 50
c'est bien c'est moi c'est le meilleur
temps des missions
alors voici faut pas chômé choix d'ali
chantal tchad m
donc toi tu vois c'est d'avoir la bonne
réponse non je participe pas c'était dur
en janvier dernier intitulé le glacier
du haut arctique canadien
succombera-t-il bientôt au changement
climatique
point d'interrogation on n'a pas le
droit faire des affirmations ne peuvent
être que des points d'interrogation
une règle bon voici alice québec le
canada se préoccupe des effets des
changements climatiques de sa propre
zone de glaces nordique donc elle
écrivait que l'arctique canadien
représente un pourcentage important de
toute la masse continentale du canada
voici la question
l'arctique représente tel pourcentage de
tout le canada de superficie du canada
est ce que ca attendu
est-ce que c'est 20 % est-ce que cbs que
c'est 30 %
est ce que c'est c'est 40 % ou est-ce
que céder aucune de ces réponses
aucune de ces rapports n'ont pas de
parti ou du cercle opa du canada à
partir au canada
vous parlez de quoi la pesée l'attendait
la zone arctique représente quel
pourcentage de la fusée canadien de la
santé de tout le canada
aucune the tout le canada
je t'ai pas les 30% 40% et 20%
aucune de ces 20 % 20 % à 29 ans c'est
le maximum donc que sa réponse ou du
canada dans mon introduction le mot part
importante partie important pour moi on
peut le trouver sur le site web si vous
lui même on envoie la réponse à un
attentat importante
oui quelle portion du canada représente
j'ai rien à 30 % 30 %
voici la bonne réponse vous avez tous
répondu ok
qui c'est qui a répondu 40% moi j'ai
répondu trente quatre ans désolé qui est
plus proche à tout le monde termine avec
20 points
il ya beaucoup de cette pension vraiment
important on est projeté et les gens
simples tout en moi j'aurais pas dit que
j'aurais jamais dû prendre mais moi
j'étais dans les 30 % moi je n'aurais
jamais osé écrire une affaire très bon
écoutez on est prêt pour l'image de la
semaine
bien sûr maestro on présente notre
musique d'accompagnement temps je répond
par oui ou par non
vous passez pas du tout est maintenant
attendu ça se passe au canada
ça s'est passé au canada en partie assez
aujourd'hui c'est
ça s'est passé 7
ça s'est passé cet univers politique non
mais ça peut être un lien éventuellement
avec vous parce que souvent des animaux
les humains les animaux ont subi les
conséquences de ça on a des animaux en
politique forcé les nommer ces animaux
qui ont subi une conséquence évidemment
la température le froid le froid vous
vous êtes très chaude des animaux qui
ont subi une conséquence quelque chose
nous aident à gilly les chevaux animale
canada en partie fois animal un autre
indice infecter les êtres humains aussi
j'en suis sûr
non mais
[Musique]
c'est relié au froid s'abat lyon froid
et qu'elle est l'expression qui revenait
souvent cette stat canard qua non ça
c'est en france sont des canards nous on
a des droits
donc oui donc vous avez essentiellement
l'image de la semaine et voici images
présentées par reuters ça se passe au
ministre a donc tout juste au sud de la
frontière canadienne dans l'ouest
canadien
c'était mercredi c'est donc des
pantalons des jeans jeu l'écossais
l'avait on les a mais eni total
j'ai parlé des états unis ben oui je
n'ai entre nous et jeudi en partie en
partie une belle image on n'est pas dans
ses airs il le froid avec des trous
sillars matches possibles avec les 20 là
à montréal ça transperçait les pantalons
des mains c'est le jour de la marmotte
calaisis la marmotte la maudite à ces
deux côtés de la frontière
généralement non très souvent puis ce
que vous connaissez la marque le nom de
la marque canadienne n'ont fait au fait
une petite recherche sur merci marc
moyen de plus de marmottes home canadian
y en a dans les maritimes bienvenue en
ontario qui est décédé je pense alors
qu'ils n'y a pas de règle et congelés
matin
canada canada pourrait aussi chercher
écureuils les marmottes sont de la même
famille que les écureuils
ouais non pas sur google mais sur
sina.com indienne ils vont vous passez
de pubis et la marmotte mais on aurait
pu également c'est un peu long à jour
des matches et voilà le moteur de
recherche a soufflé de la votre marmot
annoncera t dans laquelle vous voulez
importance à lui à ces noces agression
2018 selon le plus récent donc la
marmotte à des résidents encore en vie
celle-là non à 2010 baissé suite la
brune mais c'était leur dernier une
tradition ça revient chaque année alors
winnipeg willow et balzac berry 12,3
célèbre marmotte manitoba c'est quoi la
date limite pour que ça pour que ce
forfait
on est le premier bonne idée mais je
vois ces deux heures l'après midi fred
la marmotte du québec bon marmaille
commencera au cymbalta cif
oui ça va et hâtifs le printemps du
soleil
je pensais passer ça faudrait lire
l'article vous mettez mahmat dans notre
site
un principe sera safer la gérer la
réponse à votre question très bien donc
rapport le printemps est aux portes
bientôt
moi je pomme j'oserais pas écrire ça non
là notre ami n'ira pas s'inventer du
soleil
la neige au parc jean drapeau ah oui
avec moi j'aime pas oublier l'image
parce qu'en fait il ya quelques jours
c'est ça ouais jours de cela il s'est
rendu au parc jean-drapeau comme pour un
pique nique en plein été ouais il s'est
installé un parasol cuit des lunettes de
soleil
puis il s'est affiché avec de la neige
partout un froid glacial
je vais demander mais dans le fond
qu'est-ce que tu essayais de fin il m'a
dit j'ai cherché du soleil basé à
l'occasion de deux mois c'est trop
c'est à l'occasion de la fête des neiges
allez sur le site non non c'est ma faute
aux personnes là c'est l'autre je t'ai
fait il me l'a envoyé et j'étais comme
si et des rires une telle photo en plein
hiver puisque ont réduit de ses travers
personnel il à manger de la poutine ce
palais et y revenant sur la québécoise
de la poutine avant midi c'était un
petit léger les photos là pour sortir de
l'émission je trouve que c'est quelque
chose de vraiment amusant quand il faut
la semaine prochaine on peut plus
contenir le soleil commun voilà la
vérité de la marmotte avant de montrer
le sujet de l'émission la semaine
prochaine déjà tout décidé comment on
passe à l'antenne elle s est montré la
voie là je sais pas si c'est ce que la
table ronde la montre avec le pied
quelque chose parce qu'on réponde à mes
on voit quand même temps j'en vois sur
votre groupe
ouais on voit très bien voilà on va
commencer murs et un brin plus endettés
prochaine
[Musique]